Voilà, je procède presque deuxm,
Walid Hijazi, avocat, et avec,
Amélie Desmarais, journaliste
qui a suivi ce procès. Bonsoir.
Je commence à vous, Wal
Qu'est-ce que la Couronne devait
prouve
meurtre au deuxième degré?
Rappeleuxième degré,
qu'est-ce qu'il fallait tr
pour deuxième degré?t pas entres
deux. Un meurtre est un meurtre.
Le niveau de préméditation, un
d'avance. Onpas dans cpas danss
c'est pas premier degré, ça peut
être deuxiè, mes qui a
causé la mort de quelqu'un en
toute connaissance de cause,eu r
ou faire quelque chose que l'on
sait est de natuauser la
mort, causer des blessures qui
peuvent provoquer la mort eterse
involontaire coupable, c'est-à-
dire aquelque chosevictimvictims
l'intention de tuer. Ici, ça se
jouait sur l'intention et
Madameoigner, avait dit
qu'elle a effectivement admit la
e fait de
l'avoir barricadé, enroulé avec
du ruban, mais elle a dit
qu'elle a jamais pensé que
n'a pas été crue par le jury.
- Elle disait qu'on aurait
pour homicide involontaire, elle
disait : jouis, j'ai fait ça,
mais je voulais ce que la défené
plusieurs fois pendant ses
plaidoiries, elle avait juré
qu'elle n'avait pas l'intention
de la tuer, qu'e
de ruban adhésif directement sun
avait mis de façon transversale,
un peu plus tôt dans la matinéee
jury n'a clairement pas resa vet
très émotive quand elle disait :
non, j'ai jamais voulu qu'elle
meurt,ité, mais ité, mais ité, e
la poursuite a dit dans ses
plaidoiries, c'e
t la filière,
qu'elle avait un
elle, il faut le dire que le
procureur Bussière a été très
efficace dans sa pet
probablement que ça a joué dans
le verdict et surtout la
rapidité avec laquelle il a étéa
rarement vu ça, en moins de
quatre heures, on est prê
dit que bien avant la fin convae
intention de donner la mort.
- Il devait ê
cette intention, manifestement,
ils n'ont pas le délibéré très
longtemps alors
semaines, 26 témoins, une
matière quand
notions endroits qui ne sont pas
simples, mais effectivement, ils
ont passé tout ce temps
ensemb
regarder, focaliser uniquement
sur ce dossier. Alors, on
présume que laridé a été fmomens
délibérations, ils ont dû
confirict.
- Dans quelle mesure, parce que
les jurés ne viennent pas de la
le
Québec de l'annonce de la mort
de cette jeune f
martyre de Granby, dans quelle
mesure on n'a pas voulu aussi,
au-delà des détails, punir la
belle-mère, qui a fait des
gestes impardonnables et que
c'était presque
- Je voudrais qu
surprenant, la vitesse à
laquelle on a réussi à
sélectionner le jury, ça avait
lieu à Trois-Rivières parce que
ça avait lieu à Granby etuver du
jury pour que les gens disaient
s de bien. Je
dirais qu'on avait affaire à un
groupe de jurés très
consciencieux, pparticulièremens
que je vous dirai, ça donnait cy
rationnel, il y a eu quelques
larmes, mais honnêtement, je
dirais qu'ils étattentivement.
- La peine. Prison à vie pour un
meurtre, premier ou deuxième man
conditionnelle pour un meurtre
au deu
c'est disant, donc elle pourrait
sortir après 10 ans où il faut
attendre ce que le juge dira?
- Un minimum de 10 ans.Effective
meurtre, à peine est fixée par
le tribunal, un minimum,
perpétuité. Ce qui se décide,
c'est une admissibilité à la
libération conditionnelle.
Pour un meurtre au deuxième
degré, ça se joue entre 10 et 25
ans, c'est le juge qui va
décider. Demander aux jurys il y
avait une recomm
jury n'a pas voulu se prononcer,
ça va être au juge de décider.
Minimum de 10 ans, va devoir
faire 10 an ferme entre les murs
d'un pénitencier. Quelle sera la
peine, comment le juge va
moduler la période d'une
admissibilité à la libération
conditionnelle dans les
particularités de la désastreuse
jouée entre 10 et 20 ans, notre
individualité. Il y a plusieurs
facteurs, mais c'est le juge qui
va prendre la décision.
- Le père, qu'est-ce qui arrive
- Son procès passé, il fait face
à des accusations moins que la
belle-mère que l'on parle de
négligence criminelle causant la
mort d'avoir omis de fournir les
choses nécessaires à la vie d'ut
de séquestration, donc son
procès va s'ouvrir en janvier.sz
à un appel?
- C'est possible, on voit celatt
coupable de meurtre, c'est le
pire décret, servi avec la plusl
s'essaye en appel, ce n'est pas
la légère, il faut trouver des
motifs d'appel, des erreurs, ce
qu'on qualifie d'erreur, alors
quand ça passe devant jury, on
ne connaît pas le délibéré, ses
secrets, alors les avocats
regardent les directives puisque
le juge a payable avec les
instructions qu'
endroits, est-ced'erreur dans ln
d'expliquer c'est quoi un
meurtre au deuxième degré,
expliquer la séquestration, le
fardeau de preuve que la
présomption d'innocence, et ce
qui s'
on va regarder les clés du
processus, est-ce que le juge a
admit la preuve qu'il n'avait
pas du admis, la preuve
préjudiciable, la preuve
illégale, mais que le juge a
permis, c'est ce genre de choses
vraisemblablement, les avocats
vont vérifier ses aspects.
- En terminant ce que vous avez
couvertes procède à des dans la
carrière de journaliste, il y a
marquent. Vous serez marqué par
cela inévitablement.
- Il y a une intensité tellement
grande dans un processus comme
celui-là, d'être assise dans une
des choses extrêmement dures,
mais arrivera aussi des moments
de solidarité entre
journalistes, avoir un juge qui
a quand même une certaine
répartie, avoir des échanges
également entre les avocats,s, r
aussi avec la grand-mère de
cette fille qui nous a
longuement entretenu les
journalistes, qui était très
généreuse, ça été vraiment un
processus marquant, touchant, de
façon pour moi effectivement.
- Personne ne sort de la en
disant qu'on crie victoire, il y
a eu beaucoup de sobriété
la réaction des procureurs, il a
dit que c'est une façon de
rendre la dignité à cette jeunee
ou de défaite, il y a une
tristesse des deux côtés.
- Effectivement, vous faites
bien de le souligner, c'est pas
une célébration, c'était un
moment difficile, une histoire
tragique, une hidifficile, ça nn
procès simple, c'est délicat,
trèle monde, pour toutes les
parties, pour les avocats, les
témoins, pour l'accuser aussi,
la fam
c'est ce que les procureur de la
Couronne et la famille de la
victime ont le résultat qu'ils
ont souhaité, mais ce n'est pas